and Ukraine says it's making gains in
the offensive against Russian forces to
recapture bakmuth
the city in eastern Ukraine has been at
the heart of fierce fighting for months
Ukraine's Armed Forces released video
showing what it said was soldiers
storming Russian positions assadbag has
more from chromatosk in eastern Ukraine
Regional military Administration has
said that they believe it was a rocket
attack they've released some images that
show buildings damage to buildings but
also individuals that have been killed
they say one woman is out on a bike ride
another man was loading his vehicle to
go away with his family for the weekend
now Limon was in the hands of the
Russians last year but the ukrainians
reminded a counter-offensive last year
and took it back but since there then it
has been under constant attack by the
Russians now Limon is also is a place
where there's a key Railway Junction in
eastern Donetsk now the ukrainians say
that they have repelled several attacks
from the Russians but this latest rocket
attack comes just days after the
Ukrainian military said that it had
noticed a gathering of Russian forces in
the liman direction they say around 120
000 Russian soldiers were gathering in
the liman kopiansk direction elsewhere
in the Easter ukrainians say that
they're making gains near Bahamut to the
North and South although that's very
difficult to corroborate but in reality
that there's real no real change on the
front lines here in the East although
there are constant air raid sirens and
sand of artillery being fired but also
strikes coming back going on throughout
the day and night I said Big Al Jazeera
kravatorsk eastern Ukraine